Now let's introduce another problem.
We have a cavern here with a rickety bridge connecting it.
On this side, which we'll call "here," we have a collection of 4 people
who want to get to the other side, which we'll call "there."
Part of the problem is this is nighttime, and it's dark.
Fortunately, our team has a flashlight or a torch.
The setup is such that the bridge is so rickety that only 2 people at a time
can cross, so either one or two people can cross.
It's so dark that they need the flash light with them.
For everybody to get across, two people are going to have to go across.
One is going to have to come back with the flashlight.
They'll shuttle each back and forth like that.
Now, each of the people has different physical abilities and fear levels,
so they each take different times to cross the bridge.
This person is speedy, takes 1 minute, 2 minutes, 5 minutes, and 10 minutes.
The question is what combinations of actions will get everybody across the bridge the fastest.